[inaudible]
joining me today as a gorilla journalist,
the head of Project Veritas and the
author of American Prob de James O'keefe.
Welcome to the Rubin report.
Great to be here.
Long overdue I think is the way I'm going
to start this one because you are sort
of right in the center of a lot of the
things that I'm constantly talking about.
So it's good to have you. Great to be
here. Thanks for having me. Okay, so, uh,
before we get into all your work that
I think most of my audience knows,
at least a portion of, I don't think
anyone knows that much about you.
What do we need to know about James
O'keefe, the man? How did he become this,
this rogue reporter and guy that was
unearthing all of the evil things that are
tech overlords are doing to us?
Well, I started in college doing
these undercover tapes. Uh,
I actually started 15 years ago,
started a newspaper in
college called the Centurion.
And I quickly learned that the way to
expose these institutions is to sort of
make them live up to their own principles.
Like the Alinsky tactic.
I'd read rules for radicals by
Saul Alinsky in college and I,
I decided to expose hypocrisy by
making them live up to their own rules.
And I realized that those rules were
race and sex and sort of abortion,
these sort of sacred cow institutions,
planned parenthood and acorn.
And I decided to use hidden cameras.
I went into the dining hall at Rutgers,
I on Saint Patrick's Day and I said that
lucky charms offends my Irish heritage.
They took me seriously and told
us they would remove lucky charms.
Cereal is the first video that I did.
And from there I actually went on
to work with, uh, uh, Lila rose,
who you had on the show recently and some
and planned parenthood investigations.
Acorn with Andrew Breitbart and I have
done some 200 undercover investigations
in the last 10 years.
I assume as you
do more undercover things and now
you've got other people that are,
that are doing a portion of them,
it gets harder and harder to do as
people know who you are and know the
organization and things.
You'd be surprised. I mean it, the
moment we read the Society of waste,
fraud and abuse,
I suppose we will win the day,
but people are always
going to be in power,
tends to corrupt and absolute
power corrupts absolutely.
And money and, and, uh,
things that develop.
People all are always going to be corrupt.
So I don't actually wear the
camera these days very often.
I sort of go out into the field to,
to be a leader to the troops.
But for the most part it's,
it's,
we've got dozens of these people across
the United States with wearing these
little cameras. You put them in, you
can put them in a cup for, you know,
you can put them in a book, you can put
them in a watch. And as long as you're,
I ask you if there's more
than four cameras in the
studio right now. Cause I got,
there's a war. There's a few over
there. Yes. Um, but you know,
but as long as there's one party
consenting to the conversation,
as long as that you're,
you're talking to someone,
there's no expectation of privacy.
We would argue.
And we won in federal court in
Massachusetts a few months ago. We,
we changed the law.
So it's,
we believe that secretly recording
someone is a fundamental human right.
It's a constitutional right
because I have no duty.
Keep confidential what you tell me.
So the hidden camera is an extension of
the reporter notebook and the cameras
capture things that words don't, I mean
cameras capture, intonation, inflection.
And so we believe that this is a kind
of transparency revolution and there's a
movement of people doing
this in a weird way.
It is sort of depressing reality.
Like when I've watched some of your
videos and you get engineers at these
companies and we're going to, we're
going to talk about all of them, uh,
to admit things that we all are sort
of thinking or true related to shadow
banning or d boosting where everything
else, there's a piece of me,
even when they're, they're tipping off
the information that I suspect is true.
There's a piece of me that's
like, this is, this is,
there's something sort of depressing
about this that this is what we've been
left with. Like we have
to go after, you know,
mid level and sometimes low level
engineers and sometimes the bigger ones.
But because there's no transparency
when it comes to these companies.
So it feels almost depressing to me.
Does that mean, does that make sense?
I think the way that I would put it,
like it's unfortunate, I suppose I,
some people call it depressing,
some people say it. Could
we confirm suspicions?
I would say that what we do is
summon righteous indignation, uh,
at the tragedies in society,
including in these organizations
because they run so counter to what were
spoonfed the narratives that
were spoon fed by the media,
by the powers that be so Hidden Camera
Journal and investigative reporting,
whether it's hidden camera or print
does that it summons what I to Tarbell
termed as righteous indignation at the
tragedies. And it kind of, you know,
most people, I would say 80%, there's
a sort of consensus around what we do.
People say, well that's wrong
or they deny it. So Twitter, uh,
Twitter lobbyist in
Congress under oath said,
we do not shadow banned when his
engineer clearly said what we do.
Do is shadow band and we,
I don't know if we do that anymore.
That's what the engineer said. Clearly
meaning that he had shadow banned people.
So, um, it's, it's perjury to
lie under oath and, and you know,
these hidden camera videos really show
people what's going on at angers people.
I think the world is more
polarized than it was 10 years ago.
So maybe that 80% consensus
is, is, is going down.
Are you worried at all though that will
always be videotaping each other and
that there will be nothing that's private.
I mean, even now if I go out to dinner,
like I'm aware that I'm some level of
a public person and sometimes people
recognize me and sometimes I was at the
airport and it was very obvious to me
that the guy,
I was sitting with somebody,
but that the guy next to me clearly knew
who I was and he was on his computer
and the whole time I can think of this
guy could be recording me, you know? And,
and just all like just this
endless big brother thing.
Even if the intentions of what you're
doing. I do believe to be good.
Are you just worried about just that
general state of we're all going to be
recording each other all the time?
There will be nothing private.
I'm not worried at all.
I mean there's an element of risk every
time you interact with strangers and you
talk to them, as long as there's one
party present to the conversation,
we would argue that it's ethical.
And again,
we think that camera's visuals are
merely an extension. I mean I could,
I could disseminate what
you tell me in private.
I could write it down and shout it from
the rooftops opt ins and clarity wrote
the jungle. He saw everything and then
he ran back to his hotel and wrote,
wrote it all down.
So surely society would would,
would rather a situation
where I accurately capture
what it is that you told me
and I have to use cameras. They indemnify
me because people call me a liar.
They say that didn't happen.
So I have to,
I have to record the
incidents because they would,
they would say that it did not
happen the way that I reported it.
And they also think that I think that
there are lines that we can't cross.
We don't go into people's bedrooms, we
try to stay away from the really personal,
intimate, you know, sexual
details about, about people.
But this is a revolution that's
aimed at the power structure at this
establishment, the powers that be not
against private citizens. And we don't.
And I think there was a duty,
there is a responsibility
that investigative reporters
have not to put people on
blast unless it really meets
a compelling public interest.
So you mentioned you started this in,
in college.
What was tipping you off to like that
there was something wrong with the media?
I mean,
what made you go,
I gotta go in there and say I'm Irish
and I'm offended by Leptin charms.
Like what really was happening that
you were seeing that led to that? Well,
I was in at Rutgers University in New
Jersey and it was so the political
correctness was run a muck like
most schools and all these daily,
there's something bad happening with the
grease trucks please. The grease trucks,
trucks, trucks, please tell
me that they're okay. It's
for those who don't know,
they're these trucks at Rutgers and it's
like they're all in the parking lot and
uh, and you get real fat real quick,
older, your collar, there was something,
you know what? There was something wrong
with the gross trucks. They had duct,
they'd put duct tape. This is
in 2005, over these sandwiches.
Am I allowed to curse on them?
There was one of them called the fat,
the fat bitch and the fat,
a dyke and other words that
were offensive. And um,
they had put duct tape over the names
because these words were considered
offensive. That's what was the, like what
compelled me to try to ban lucky charms.
So I said, this is ridiculous. I also
had professors who were Stalinists.
I had professors who were telling me
how great communist Communism was.
And I was not political,
but I read the New York Times every day
front to back in college in the dining
hall. I was sort of an
introverted guy and I'd read,
read the paper and I was just, I said,
this doesn't accurately capture the world.
This doesn't, this doesn't tell
people what's really going on. So I,
I felt compelled to do something
about it and it wasn't comfortable.
It's not comfortable to confront
people with cameras and, you know,
get into their faces.
But I was willed to do it because I
believed in the cause and, and the,
the kind of Alinsky, uh, methodology,
which is to make them accountable
to their own principles. You know,
you had these Marxist professors driving
Bentleys and BMWs and had a little muck
raking newspaper and it was
like lifestyles of the rich
and Marxist. Right, right.
You know, track these people down. I
just feel that most people that do this,
most insiders inside these companies
coming to us now have what I call it
justice complex.
They think that there are things wrong
with the world and they feel compelled to
do something about it. It's
hard to explain. Uh, but
you know, I'm sure you know,
people who have this complex and these
people are willing to basically jump on a
grenade to wear a camera,
to film their employer.
Some cases violating their
own nondisclosure agreement
because they believe the
public has a right to
know what they're seeing.
Are you shocked at the amount of people
at these big tech companies who now are
willing to speak?
Because I mean I know insiders
that I get some information from,
I mean I'm talking about Google,
Facebook,
Twitter like that really these things
have become so huge that now their own
people inside them are going, Whoa,
what, what did we help create here?
I'm not sure. Got a frack,
a Frankenstein Monster.
I mean I have you been to Menlo Park and
you go to San Francisco and I was there,
cause I did this Facebook story,
this insider inside Facebook and I went
to try to locate these engineers and ask
them for comment.
And there were just these buses,
just hundreds of buses filled
with millennials and end,
if you go to the campus, people are
sort of driving around these bicycles.
The best word I can describe
it as their minions.
It's to sort of this little totalitarian
little mini state within a state.
And it's just a group think or,
well Ian Place and I,
and I guess the,
the word that it was described to me by
the insights that they're all minions.
They're very intelligent people but they
don't have a lot of common sense and
there, and I, and I went there,
I was amazed by this Menlo
Park campus buses of,
of young people being bused in.
And I think that it doesn't surprise
me that people are willing to blow the
whistle because there's more to
life than, than making, you know,
a quarter million dollars a
year and working for these
companies. People want to,
people want to do something. One of the
things that I get told all the time,
what can I do? And, and there aren't a lot
of choices for people. You know, you can,
you can watch the shows,
you can buy the books,
but some people want to actually
participate in this country. And,
and solutions are increasingly, you
know, outside the scope of government,
the legislative process does not
seem to solve things. So there's,
there needs to be in a
different counterweight.
There needs to be a different solution
and I would say that 0.001% of people are
like put a camera on me. That's a lot of
people by the way. Yeah, right, right,
right. We're talking about a lot
of people at the end of the day.
So when did you realize that because
you've mostly focused or at least I think
the the,
the work that has gotten you the most
attention has been related to the tech
companies, not necessarily going
after politicians or academics per se,
although you've done some of that.
When did you realize that focusing
on the tech companies was,
was really the thing that was going to
strike the chord with most people because
that's what it seems to be. Well, because
I think the media has all the power.
I think that I've known this for ever
since I started this endeavor was that the
media has so much more
power than people realize.
Everyone knows the media is powerful,
but I think that people fear the
humiliating power of the press.
I think the press,
including the big tech companies
have more power than government.
They are more powerful
than all three branches of
government, executive, judicial,
legislative branch. So somehow we
need to hold these people accountable.
They're not a cat, they're not held
accountable by anybody who elects them.
And I don't know what the
solutions are. People say, well,
what should they be regulated?
I think they should be transparent
or there will need to be regulated,
but they have to at least
not deceive the people.
So because the media has all the power,
I,
I wrote this book called American Proverb
de and I believe that people don't
know that they're being lied to by CNN
and the New York Times and they don't
know that they're being d boosted in
shadow, banned by Twitter and Facebook.
And I think these companies need
to tell you that they're doing it.
It's not so bad if they take
your account down and restore it.
But the thing that's really scary about
the d boosting and the shadow banning is
that you don't know that it is
happening to you. And I have to see it.
You can kind of feel it.
There are times when everything I'm
doing is on fire or then sometimes where
it's just like nothing happens and those
usually have a certain political bent
to them and then you end up really feeling
like you're in a mental institution
because if you don't have
evidence of anything,
I don't want to be the guy that's
running around and screaming,
everything's a conspiracy and they're
coming after me and leaving the rest.
We're doing this on youtube right now.
And even when you do have evidence,
like we have video tape after
tape of people inside Twitter,
including the Twitter direct messaging
guy saying that they have certain key
words and they consider
to be a Russian Bot.
If you tweet about God
guns and the American flag,
most of these engineers are not,
some of them are not American citizens.
Then they don't share American values.
And this individual says,
if you tweet about fly, he's who
talks like that, who talks about God,
you must be a Russian Bot.
I have the videotape and they still,
they still say it's fake. So, you
know, I think that what, you know,
it's one of those things where people
need to see this stuff and the lead and
that just want these companies
to be honest about what
they're doing. They just,
I just want them to be honest. That's
why I want to be honest though. I mean,
we want them to be honest, right? So I'm
with you. I want them to be honest and,
and the reason I apply
as much pressure on them,
on Twitter and youtube particularly is
because I want them to be better. Right?
Like I, I always say this, it's
like I've got a million subscribers.
I put out a television quality
show on Youtube for free,
and I don't even have an email
address to someone at Youtube.
I have no contact at someone at Youtube.
Like that's rigid. Timidly crazy.
They're a huge company
that offers a product.
I'm a user of the product that helps make
them money through advertising and all
that stuff. I can't even
get a human there, but I,
but I don't think I can force
them to be better. Right. Well,
it's the job of investigative reporting
to hold people accountable to, to,
to test and affirm what
is an outrage to people.
And I think that you can't lie
under oath. You can't. I mean,
Mark Zuckerberg said in,
in Congress last spring,
some things that may be contradicted by
some of the documents we've unearthed,
there are laws against perjury and the,
and what people have to remember is I
don't have a position on whether these
companies should be regulated.
I honestly don't know what should be done.
I do know that people need to know
what is happening inside the companies,
and I think that because
they're so powerful, people
have no idea you when you,
when you digest content from
CNN and the New York Times,
all that stuff gets filtered
through Facebook. In fact,
when I did the Facebook story,
I was shocked by some people in
media telling me, while I don't know,
I love the story, but I don't
know if I can cover it. Why not?
Because we derive most of
our revenue from Facebook.
The same thing happened during
the 2016 election. When I,
when I did the Hillary Clinton tapes
and the Bob Creamer resigned. I mean,
people have to remember that these
companies are publicly traded companies.
They get their broadcast
license from the FCC.
In some circumstances there
sort of entanglements.
There's a symbiotic relationship between
the corporate press and the government.
And for those reasons,
again,
to go back to the campaign
to recruit insiders,
it's going to require citizens.
It's gonna require outsiders to blow
the whistle because no one in the
government is going to do it. Indeed,
many of them around the take. Okay.
So let's just do each platform or one at
a time. So you just mentioned Facebook.
So let's go to phase.
What do,
what do we need to know about what's
going on with the Facebook algorithm and
the way they're banning
people in suspending people
and the rest of it? Well,
I can tell you what our insider told us,
saying I can,
I try to only speak about
the things that I know.
100% in the insider was
working in the content review,
uh,
the content review tool at Facebook.
And she was a contractor
for the company and she, uh,
leaked us documents inside the company
showing I guess what would be called as a
de boost of a live stream video.
And she said she specifically saw
this on Steven Crowder's page. Um,
uh,
she saw it on a few other pages.
She took a screenshot of a Mike Cernovich
page and on the page it says I action
live distribution.
This was apparently some type of algorithm
written too from what we could see,
two to reduce content that
was suicidal or violent,
but none of these
individuals were talking or,
or doing anything that
would rise to that level.
And now there's two different parts of
Facebook. People need to understand.
There is a task system where it seems
like Facebook after the election hired
hundreds if not thousands of people to
monitor. And they do a fairly good job.
If your page gets taken down,
it can be reinstated,
you can file a complaint and they,
they have a pretty good process.
But then there's another part of Facebook
that this insight or told us about or
these were,
this algorithm was occurring.
And it was occurring automatically and
they were identifying certain key words.
So she leaks us this troll report,
it's called a troll report.
And after the election, Facebook decided
to Chino to get more involved in,
in,
in things,
I guess they didn't like the outcome of
the election and maybe that's what this
was. It was really about, I mean,
independent people having an impact on,
on society.
They don't,
they don't like that and they're
in hitting needs more control.
So they had this troll report.
There are certain key words, uh,
words that we're not racist or,
or problematic really,
but they were words that were appropriated
by, by right wing meme culture,
words like lulls and normy.
And even the, even the, the,
the MSM mainstream media
was in this troll report.
Since typically right wingers
use MSM more than the left.
And these are just words or phrases or
acronyms that usually are just men in
meme. Funny Sharon, silly ways. These
are not a threat to democracy. Msm,
mainstream media is not an implication
of racism. Well, they also blow up,
brought up Lauren Chen, they,
they, they brought her up. It was,
she was in there as an example of
someone who is needs to be dealt with.
Visa VI, the, the, uh, the product
intervention at Facebook. And I don't,
I don't know, I'm not aware of any
of any activities or problems with,
with her videos. I mean, she's just
someone who's sharing her mind on youtube.
I'm not sure what order
we're putting these up in,
but I've got Laura and chat and
coming in here. That's so cool.
Well that says it's a cosmic coincidence.
So, so she likes us these documents,
uh, we put the story out instantly.
What happens is the press, uh,
the verge was the name of the outlet
comes out, comes to Facebook's defense.
It always happens, by the way,
we did the story on Twitter.
And instantly buzzfeed comes out of the
Twitter says they don't do this because
that's not, that's not journalism. I mean,
Twitter says the job of
investigative reporting is to,
is to question what they tell you.
But it's always the case when we do these
videos that people come out and they
said, well, they say
they don't do this. Um,
and they came to Facebook's defense. But
the truth is these documents were real.
And the two engineers that we interviewed,
a guy named Sagey Yamamoto and Danny,
Ben,
David actually confronted these guys on
the street in San Francisco with a film
crew because no one would
give me any answers.
But the documents are pretty self
explanatory and it's, it's definitely, um,
it definitely,
I don't know if Mark Zuckerberg knows
that these things are happening,
but if he does, he was lying
under oath. Right. So wouldn't,
the sensible thing to do if you are mark
Zuckerberg would be make sure that you
don't really know what's going on at
your company so that when you get put in
the position where you're under oath,
you can basically say anything.
And I think this would
stand true for jacket,
Twitter and a bunch of these guys
if the buck never stops with you.
And I'm sure you saw, um, Jack from
Twitter on with Joe Rogan and Tim Pool.
And it was like, he just struck me as, oh,
I don't really know what's
going on with my company,
but that seems like it's by design. It's
not an accident. That's interesting. Um,
uh, there's a book by Blake Harris out
in the last couple of weeks about Palmer
Luckey and Facebook,
and I encourage you to read it.
It's unbelievable that this guy, uh, uh,
Palmer Luckey who founded the Oculus,
the virtual reality software was, uh,
was dealt with by Mark Zuckerberg
directly inside the company.
He was told not to be a Trump supporter,
him on the show actually. So, um, I,
I don't,
I don't know whether that's true or not.
I did see a Jack Dorsey,
uh,
he's never addressed
anything we've exposed,
they don't want to deal
with the actual evidence.
There's video tapes of Obenauf of a driver
was saying one strategy is to shadow
banned. I mean, there's, they don't
want to actually address the evidence.
They want to say, well,
they don't know what they're
talking about. Well, you know,
and by the way,
there is a difference between,
I think anytime you have human beings
in a room making content decisions,
subjectively you're going
to have these problems.
These are hard problems to solve.
But it goes back to the original point
of hiring hundreds if not thousands of
people do the content review.
I think at the end of the day,
if these companies don't
like an independent people
influencing the minds of
other people,
that's what this is really about.
And that would actually be okay if they
were transparent about it, sort of,
because then it would allow
competition to fill that void.
But this sort of neither here nor
there and instead of it seems to be the
problem. So, okay, so d boosting seems
to be the main problem with Facebook.
And that's interesting that
it was hitting Crowder videos,
Lauren and Shannon and a couple of
other people, and this means you're,
you're streaming, right? So this means
when he's streaming that the, the number,
it's just not going to feed,
is that
right? It's, it's when you're,
when you do a live stream video,
there are special tags, there are
special qualities in that live stream,
and they down rank the video,
they take away some of the
special qualities that make
it automatically show up
on other people's timelines according
to the insider that we spoke to.
The other thing about these videos
that are live streamers that they're
converted to text automatically
and machine learning goes
through the video and
identifies these keywords. So yes,
the video would be down ranked.
It would have its special
qualities taken away. And, uh,
I think that Crowder settled out
of court in 2016 with Facebook.
It's what he told me.
And I think that he's in the process of,
of doing some more litigation related to
some of the things they're doing to his
videos.
Yeah. Is there anything else that you
need to know on the Facebook front?
You've said they've gotten a
little bit better when it comes to,
they would ban people in suspend
people left and right all the time.
I used to have my, my friend Faisal Omar,
who's been on the show many times, who's,
uh,
an ex Muslim from,
from Iraq and really working
to secularize the Arab world.
I mean doing incredible, incredible
work. I mean, this is a good man.
He would get banned all the
time, right? And I would have,
I had a contact there so I was
able to help him get back on that.
Seems to be happening a
little bit less now. I logged
in there, the, the insiders showed
me how it works. There's it,
I guess what you call a task
function and um, and you know,
someone gets there. There are, there
are independent people in the company,
low level people who just make arbitrary
decisions to remove people and then
that's wrong and they shouldn't do that.
So there are adult supervision in the
room. There are, there are people,
there's like a conversation
thread under each task.
They convert these things
into what they call tasks.
And there are adults that say,
well that's no good.
And there relationships with a
lot of the publishers for um,
entities like such as your own. And, and,
and there was a relationship between a
sales rep at Facebook and there seemed to
be adult supervision.
But the problem is with the algorithm
side of things as far as I can see.
So He's part of it that the algorithm,
in many cases they will,
the algorithms were written by people,
you know, 10 years ago or 15 years ago,
probably aren't at the company anymore.
Nobody really like who really understands
what's going on with these algorithms.
Do the engineers at these companies even
have a sense of what's really going on
and how can they make sure that they're
not manipulated by the low level people
in? Well, one of the problems I have is a
reporter doing this is trying to, I mean,
I'm not a tech person.
I'm not a,
I don't claim to have any
special expertise is trying to,
people's eyes glaze over when you start
talking about machine learning and uh,
and,
and SSI livestream distribution.
So trying to get the people indignant
about something that they have no idea
what this means. But
yes, I think Danny, Ben,
David wrote the algorithm at Facebook in
2017 than it was apparently intended to
address violence or suicidal content.
And we believe that it was a applied
to politics and it was used for ill.
That seems to be what
happened at Facebook.
So you're saying the road to hell is
paved with good intentions, right?
Is that what you're telling me?
Uh,
anything else going on in Facebook
that we need to know about it? And,
and do you sense that Zuckerberg may
be because of being hauled in front of
Congress will do anything?
I can tell you that everyone inside
the company knows what we did. And uh,
there's one,
I don't know how many 60,000 employees,
they all know exactly what we did.
And I think that when we personalize
it by going to the men went to the
engineer's doors,
we went to,
we went to the train station where the
guy gets on the train every morning and I
interviewed him and he said, I fear for my
safety. He's like, I'm scared. I'm like,
you're scaring.
I should be afraid for my safety.
I mean you guys are the ones spying
on us and taking our videos down and,
and not to that, but I'm going after
this trillion dollar company. Um,
but we personalized it.
And I think that there's a lot in,
since I released this tape a month ago,
there have been many people inside the
company that have approached me and I'm
trying to,
you know,
it's always the question of do you want
to wear a camera or do you just want to
feed me things anonymously?
My medium is video.
I think that there has to be video
because if we don't take these things,
no one will believe it.
So then the person has to basically
lose their job and I'll hire them.
And that's how our,
our model tends to work these days.
How do you make sure that when someone
reaches out to you that they're not just
trolling you? Like a triple agent? Yeah.
Well basically that they would reach out
to you knowing that you throw up one,
one bad thing and there's
been little moments. Yes, we
can get into. Yes. Um, that,
that's going to blow up all of the
other good work that you've done.
So there's high incentive for something
else. It's a, it's a risk. It's, I mean,
listen, what we do is very high risk
for many different reasons, which,
which we can get into I guess.
But what we do is extremely
risky and an undercover work,
you're going to get burned.
You try to use common sense.
There are things that we do. Ew, ew, ew,
ew, ew, ew, ew. Go very carefully. You,
you do your due diligence.
Oftentimes they send you something.
There is something called tortious
interference with, uh, with, you know,
violating a nondisclosure
agreement. Um, uh, the,
it's a lot of complex legal analysis,
but essentially they have to tell us
something first and then we can tell them
to film what they have told
us. So there, you know,
we have to be very careful and
we have been burned by the way,
and you probably knows about some of
those things, but for the most part,
we're 95 to 98% successful.
Not everything that people bring to us,
do we publish?
Not Every secret conversation
that I've recorded do we publish?
I think it's the choosing to publish
something at the video that we've obtained
is really where the ethical
calculation comes in. All right,
well we could probably do a show
just on Facebook, but let's,
let's move to the others because in a
certain way I think Facebook is becoming
increasingly irrelevant,
at least in the political space.
I that my judgment of
that may be slightly off,
but I just don't see that much
traction any more with young people.
Do you think that's basically fair?
I disagree. I think that Facebook,
I think that the majority of
these companies disseminate
their content through
the social media platform.
So I think that there are always going
to be relevant and there was the dominate
the market in terms of
advertising revenue, um,
even even the big news organizations,
uh,
disseminate their content through
Facebook. So I think it's,
I think they are relevant.
I don't know.
I don't know what the
trajectory of that is. Yeah.
I don't mean that they're irrelevant,
but it seems to me that the,
the conversation that I really think is
important about all of this seems to be
happening much more on Twitter.
I assume you do not necessarily that
the money and the advertising and the
mainstream media reach and all of those
things aren't relevant on Facebook,
but that the real sort of,
I don't know,
the gestalt of this or something
is on Twitter and Youtube.
So that's the last shift
there for a second. So, uh,
Twitter, I'm sure you see me,
uh, tweeting all the time about the
shadow bands and the rest of it.
So what the hell is going on
with Twitter? Well, we went,
we went undercover into Twitter and
last year in early 2018 and we caught a
number of engineers describing
a shadow banning, uh,
removing posts. When people don't know
that they're sharing their content,
they don't know that they're being banned,
that we actually have quotes from the
engineers talking about what they have
done. I mentioned earlier with
this, a direct messaging expert,
a guy named print icing who
works on the Twitter DM team,
says that he can peruse all of
your messages, your private dms.
Uh, he says that there are key words
that Twitter uses to filter tweets,
uh, the American flag, God guns. Uh,
and then then we talk to another engineer,
jump over the first one there so they
can literally look at your direct
messaging. That's what they
told us. Private direct message.
They said they have teams.
This is a guy named Clay Haynes.
So they have hundred hundreds plus
of people that end. He says, quote,
I've seen a lot of Dick pics on quote.
So I understand they have
to do some of this to, to,
to ban pornography and you know,
Gore and content.
But apparently this is what they told
us that I don't know why they'd have to
look at your private messages, but, and
they've also said that they don't do that.
Right.
So that's the thing.
Why do they say one thing in public and
another thing in private is what we've
found. But we began, I,
I try to only speak to what I can actually
a videotape of what the engineer's
said. And this Abenov for Draven guy was
there was a congressional hearing with a
lobbyist. Ted Cruz did ask
him, uh, do you do this?
And he says we do not do that.
Well then why did your engine,
your say they were doing it.
So I just think they're being dishonest.
So that's the type of sort of underhanded
tactic that they're using the shadow
banning cause you have no idea.
Again,
you just don't know when
you put something out.
Is this getting to all of
my people or is it not?
Or can some people not retweet it or the
rest of it? I mean it's a pretty clever,
if they were trying to silence people,
it's pretty clever way of doing it. Right.
I think that's the unethical part.
They don't tell people that they are
doing and they don't tell people their
political positions.
I just want them to be transparent.
I think Facebook kind a thing.
Not to go back to Facebook,
but they put out a thing. We are,
we are banning white nationalists.
Well at least they're telling
us where they stand. I'm not,
not that that is a good thing,
white nationalism.
But if they were to do more of
that sort of thing and say we are,
we are taking an editorial
perspective in the New York Times,
The Washington Post, you can see on
the op ed pages what they believe in.
They're there. They're rather transparent
about it. I would say more so.
So I think that these companies should
take an editorial position, but when,
when we hear,
um,
print icing at Twitter on the hidden
camera, say who talks like that,
who talks about God and the American
flag and guns must be a Russian Bot says
print icing at Twitter.
W I'm fine with that.
As long as you say it publicly,
as long as you make it part of your
editorial positions so that people know,
okay, this company is a,
is extremely left wing.
Do any of the Banning's or any of this
ever happened to people on the left?
I know there was some instances maybe
with Auntie Phi accounts are a couple of
things.
Like that,
but it always seems like
you have conservatives and
people on the right talking
about, yeah, I don't,
I'm not, to my knowledge,
and I think our reporting
overwhelmingly focused on,
on why he even mentioned Donald Trump's
account and insinuated that they were,
that they were working with the government
to give information to, I dunno,
deep state individuals,
and this is clay Haynes,
a network security engineer at Twitter
told us about Donald Trump's accounts. I,
I've never seen anything on the
other end of the spectrum from,
from my vantage point,
when Trump's cabinet got taken down for
those couple of hours and then it turned
out to be just, what was it? They said
it was some accident or some young,
some low level guy did it for you.
That must've been like a Whoa,
that just shows you the power that any,
any individual would have access
to be able to shut down the president.
For our, for our purposes, we're always,
I'm always trying to prove it.
Like I want to get them on tape admitting
why they did it. But there are the,
there are these,
you know,
I guess you could call them low level
people that do things that are not
acceptable. Um, and it's policed
more. So at Facebook I would say.
Yeah. Anything else going on with Twitter
and that's all that we reported on the
shadow banning the,
the,
the tr deprivate DMD messages and the
shadow banning where the big ones.
What do you make generally of the
political politization of Twitter?
Like specifically. So, you know,
if you were to click on the search bar
on Twitter on any given day and you see
the Twitter moments, it's all, you know,
they're always showing you
the Trans Story of the day or,
or whatever the left is
leaning with that day.
They're always sort of pushing
that down your throat. Um,
is that just consistent with everything
else you view these companies?
What I will say is that we have more
stories coming on, that sort of thing.
So I would, I would, uh, hold my tongue
because I don't want to scoop myself.
We've got a number of people
on the inside that are,
that are maybe focusing on the search
functions at these organizations.
So we'll, we'll, you'll be, you have to
stay tuned to see what we young, yeah,
that wouldn't surprise me.
I mean when I searched certain people,
even if they're verified,
if they happen to be on the right,
sometimes they don't pop up,
but I get a zillion random accounts
before that or I often think that the,
um, the trending tab, right, it seems like
it's completely manipulated. You know,
what they are commenting on
and what they're, you know,
cause sometimes there's a comment
beneath the trend or whatever.
It all just seems made up. And, and,
and for project Veritas, the, the
priority is to prove it is to,
is to catch them on tape admitting it.
And that is what we will do.
And we will have more stories soon
on, on all of this, all this friends.
So let's move to youtube.
We're on youtube right now.
I've had people in the past,
years ago when I did,
at one time I did have an email address
of someone at Youtube. And they told me,
cause I kept saying people
keep complaining that
they're unsubscribed from my
channel.
I kept getting emails every day and one
time someone from Youtube admitted to me,
they said,
there's a bug on your channel and we're
trying to work it out with a couple of
weeks after that,
after I followed up a few times and then
I couldn't get any more information,
I got an email from the guy saying,
I'm no longer handling this case.
And now you have to go to the,
you don't have an email
address to respond to any more,
go to the general tab and
complaint or whatever. Uh,
so I have to publicly
shame them all the time.
You probably see me doing this
with teams of Youtube and Twitter.
Every time I get demonetized I fight them.
And then they usually,
not always Lila rose, for example,
they did not remodel ties. Um,
they didn't remember.
They did not really monetize that one.
It was demonetized monetized by the
algorithm and then confirmed by manual
review.
Now that's their right to do that again.
You want some transparency with it.
Um,
but unsubscribes,
video's not going out to
feeds all of these things.
What evidence do we actually have
that these things are happening? Well,
we did a story in 2017
between the New York Times reporter
named Nick Dudek and Youtube.
And again, I can only talk about what I
report. I, that's my rule. So I don't,
I don't like to comment
on things that I don't,
I haven't had personal experience with,
but there was a relationship between
these networks like the New York Times and
hopping and post and, and Youtube.
And there, there are favors given to,
to these, uh, organizations
over say your show.
Um, and, and that's something that
we've, we've, we reported on an exposed.
So what would a favor look like?
Well,
preferential treatment and the end to
getting into the, the scientifics of it,
I'm not sure, but preferential
treatment where the video would, would,
would show up more frequently at
the top of the, of the search query.
Um,
this guy nick and Dudek who was a social
accounts video editor for The New York
Times, talked about his relationship
with this guy inside youtube.
So there's, there's a sort of, you know,
two way street there between the
two companies where favors are done,
but with the New York Times now,
why are they doing them favors? I,
that's what I was talking about earlier
where these companies have enormous
power because even the likes of the old
media transmit their messages through
the new media. That's where the majority
of people get their information from. So,
um, but that, that was that guy nick duty,
actually the executive editor of the
New York Times. Dean Baquet is his name.
Actually we believe, let that
guy go. He actually, uh, uh,
terminated Nick Dudek for
telling us this stuff.
No one reported on that.
But uh,
I don't know whether they terminated
him for telling the truth or for or for
lying about what he had said.
So how do you combat that?
The part where every time you guys
released something that I look at it,
I'm always hesitant to retweet it.
I've shared some of your videos sometimes,
but I'm always like, ah, if, if
this is the one where you know,
he got duped or you know,
it's only being shared by Breitbart or
whatever that then it's like you like
basically that you have some sort of
secondary layer of censorship to get
through.
Well,
I'll tell you what we've done to
[inaudible] to Bose and buzzfeed and CNN.
They in touching any of this.
Well, they have touched it. I mean,
Anderson Cooper reported on this stuff
we did during the 2016 election on
Hillary Clinton and Donald Trump
are stories in the 2018 election,
made the New York Times. Um, we've
gotten a lot of local media coverage.
We've been in terms of being duped,
weave,
weave in and out of 200 undercover
investigate. They say things are edited,
they're edited out of context.
They're, they're not real. I mean,
and you actually ask them what
specific edits are you talking about?
Because to say that video is edited and
it's like saying words are arranged.
All journalism is edited in to
tell a story. And they said, well,
you didn't wear the pink costume and
the acorn office will, you know, okay.
But I presented myself
as as a, as a pimp. Um,
and even the New York Times said that
and pimp protocol doesn't require wearing
of pimp, pimp if you were a big pink
jacket and drive a Cadillac. Um,
and I said, well, there was a scene
change in the NPR investigation. Okay.
Is that the best you got? I mean the, I,
there was a cutaway shot where the guy
was laughing and I was narrating over it
in 200 investigations.
I mean,
they've printed 300 corrections
and attractions about me.
I have a wall in my office called
the wall of shame and it's all these
corrections and attractions about me.
The Washington Post that I went after
acorn due to an animus about African
Americans voting. They made it up.
Pulitzer prize winning reporter Carol,
letting just made something up
out of whole cloth. So there,
I don't know, I think there is a,
I think it's not about the, um,
the, what we do is real.
The tapes. You see,
there's never been a case
where we saw wasn't real.
There was one thing with the
Washington Post that blew up.
They turn their cameras back around
on us and everyone you know said,
well that's unethical.
What exactly was unethical about it?
Because we went undercover into CNN.
We infiltrated something
called a rain Bros,
which was a a gay group
where this producer was in.
Nobody questioned the ethics of it.
Nobody questioned the ethics
because the end was so obvious.
And whether or not you think
that the means are justified,
depends upon whether you think there's a
compelling public interest and what you
are exposing.
So when these things get interrupted,
then people say it's unethical. But we
think that undercover work is justified,
particularly into the big 10 companies
and the big media due to the urgency of
the circumstances. But in
all of our work, no one's,
no one's ever able to actually say
what exactly has been fake about it.
And that's from my perspective or are
you shocked at actually how the collapse
of mainstream media has precipitated
so quickly at this point? Like,
it seems to me that it's
just, it's over. I mean now,
just in the last couple of weeks now with,
with Trump and Russia and just the amount
that these people have just lied over
and over. And finally, thanks to
Twitter and Youtube and the rest of it,
if we're not being shadow
and everything right,
there's enough of us that can get
a counter narrative out there,
but they just keep doing it. Well, I think
it's the death of, I think it's, it's uh,
uh, you've covered,
cause I watch your show,
a lot of the political
reasons why media is dying,
but I actually think it's goes back to
Jefferey's Zucker said in the last two
weeks about, I don't know if you saw
that tweet where Brian Stelter said, ah,
we're not investigators will,
that was an unbelievable moment
because that's really, they're not,
they're not investigative reporters.
And people have to remember a thing about
CNN talking about CNN, CNN, we don't,
we're not investigators where journalists,
so here's the thing.
This is very important. People talk about
politics, people talk about, you know,
the media is algorithms,
but it's also economics.
Investigative reporting is very,
very expensive and it's a
naturally philanthropic activity.
Investigative reporting,
going back 40, 50 years,
it was always a loss leader on
the company's balance sheets.
People have to remember these are,
these are businesses.
They're not interested in the public
interest. They're interested in,
in generating a profit.
And that's fine, but,
but don't pretend that you
serve the public interest.
We had a CNN insider on tape. John
Boehner field said, this is a business.
The CEO of CNN, Jeff Zucker told us, uh,
stopped talking about the climate accords.
Let's get back to Russia.
It's about ratings. It's not about
ethics. And it's been, it's been,
it's important to the story though.
You're not saying there's anything
inherently wrong with that.
He's allowed to make money. He's
allowed to do business. But,
but don't pretend you're operating in
the public interest because investigative
reporting, and let, let, let me, let me,
you had mentioned, you know, people don't,
if people are wary of what we do,
it's naturally the tip of the spear.
You have to use deception to a degree.
Either you deceive your source
or you deceive your audience.
The problem with journalism and the reason
why it's in decline is because these
leakers,
these sources and government and elsewhere
intentionally transmit stuff to the
media and they paired it to the
masses. Ai, he, Jeff Zucker saying,
we don't investigate what we're
told. And that's what you know, what,
what has been referred
to as a pseudo event.
They create something they
transmitted unquestionably.
And there's the economic factor.
There's a symbiotic relationship
between people in power.
What we do at Veritas is
we go undercover and we,
we completely defy the
narrative and that's,
and most networks don't
want to air it because,
because it's risky because
it's questioning that the
normative order of things,
it's easier to do little videos
about squirrels on skateboards.
And I did this big story
during the election, you know,
for Bob Creamer resigned from
the Hillary Clinton campaign.
And a lot of these companies say,
we're afraid that if Hillary Clinton wins,
she'll take away our FCC license.
So it's, it's, it's this,
it's this economic issue that is inherent
in media and it requires independent
people to do something about it because
the networks are not going to do
something about it. They are, they are
in the business of generating a profit.
It's so fascinating to me because it's
like they're not even in the business.
Right. I get it. So they're in the
business making a profit and that's fine.
That is what businesses,
but they're not even in the business
of pretending anymore because it's like
during the whole Mueller investigation,
every week there was another leak to
the New York Times and it's always an
anonymous leak.
And then for the last two years they ran
anonymous leaks stories and it's like,
shouldn't have, somebody had been
investigating why the Mueller, uh,
operation is leaking. That actually
would have been a story. Right.
Where was that story out of the
New York Times? Well, they had,
and James Clapper and,
and John Brennan and Munis are
intelligence discover who lied under oath.
Is there an intelligence agency people
and maybe not the most always ethical
people and they're just
parroting what they're told on,
on TV things or when things are,
and again,
I go back to this whole
distinction and because when you,
when you report from a podium, when you
say something at a press conference, the,
the damage to society
done by broadcasting,
what you are told on the record is often
more pernicious than the damage that
say I do by deceiving some guy in a bar
so that I can get the truth out of them.
It is a, it is a huge difference. And,
and I think that journalists tend to be
that you sort of have to play confidence
games. You know, you have to seduce your
source so to speak. But there's, there is,
there's a two,
there's a relationship between sources
and the media that I think has become
corrupt.
I think that the,
the anonymous or the reliance upon
anonymous sources has become corrupted.
You look at Bob Woodward, legendary
reporter that gives a great journalist,
by the way, I don't think these
journalists are bad journalists.
I don't even think they're bad people.
I think they're part of an industrial
system of production that that
manufacturers the public's consent.
But you look at Bob Woodward,
he writes a book called fear and he,
he uses quotes secondhand from
anonymous sources on background,
on deep background,
hearsay quotes,
and then he recreates events and he puts
that, those events in quotation marks.
And I get attacked for selective editing.
I don't report anything unless you can
hear and see it come out of the person's
own mouth.
So I think that,
I think that journalism has become
corrupted due to this overreliance upon
sources,
anonymous sources especially.
And I think that that's
why we need videotapes.
I literally remember being in like junior
high school and watching CNN and they
would say a source on Capitol Hill.
And I would always think this is the
same source I Capitola anyone can be on
Capitol Hill.
It could be the guy that's walking his
dog on Capitol Hill who is the janitor
for the, you know, fast food joint.
We don't, we don't see, we don't,
we don't see that sources face.
We don't know what motivates that person.
We don't know what words were used.
You know that that person exists.
We don't know if that person exists.
I mean,
can you imagine if I said
there are sources inside CNN
who says that Jeff Zucker
said they'd call me a liar. Yeah, and,
and, and I, and there's an analogy here.
I heard someone say that when
you use an anonymous source,
it's like you're taking withdrawal
out of a bank account of credibility,
but you have to deposit into the bank
account, trust with the audience.
And nowadays we don't see these,
we don't see these anonymous sources we
see on an over reliance upon and every
time you actually opened
the reporter's notebook,
every time you look at the transcript,
every time you see the raw data there,
there is a,
there is a difference between what you
are told and and by the people that are
asking you to trust them. But that's
the bottom line. These, these,
these media companies don't trust
us with the raw information.
They don't want us to have the raw,
unfiltered truth.
They need to propagandize
us with their version of it.
Yeah, it's crazy once you see it, right,
like once you really clearly see it.
Like I was actually in the green room
with Jordan Peterson while he was being
interviewed by Nellie Bowles,
who was the author of the New York
Times who made that whole brouhaha about
enforced monogamy and it's like that is
not what this conversation was about.
Or I had a whole day here,
literally an entire day from 8:00 AM
to about APM with a journalist from a
journalist,
from a Durer Spiegel who then wrote a
piece about me and labeled me the grand
illusionist of the alt right.
And it's like they're labeled
and you know what they did.
There's a light and know this at the time,
but there's a law in Germany that
if you're going to print something,
a quote from somebody,
you have to get the quote cleared.
So he spends all day with me, hours
of talking hours and hours and hours.
He doesn't quote me one.
Wow. I mean that's the level that, what
is that? It's not selective editing.
They called me the master of
ceremonies instead of an anchor.
They used the master of ceremonies.
I mean it just like what
the Washington Post Guy,
there's no sounds like grand masters.
The Washington Post,
this printed like five attractions
just in reporting about me.
It's like these guys have the
audacity to claim that I'm a liar.
In one article they said what the latest
project Veritas video leaves out and
the actual fact that I allegedly left
out was that this CNN producer that we
recorded was based in Atlanta.
Supposedly this was a big fat,
but I didn't leave it out.
It was in the video.
The Washington Post had
to print a retraction that
that they didn't change the
headline. What the what the video left
out. They retracted the entire thing.
There's another thing in the Washington
Post about this book fear and there was
a quote that said,
there's no evidence that he did not
say the things attributed to him in
referencing. There's no evidence he did
not sell. That's really good. This is,
we live in this weird world and I think
that videotape cuts through all the
propaganda,
like a hot knife through butter.
If you catch these people on videotape,
they're forced to address it.
And I think that video is, is, that's
why we choose the medium of video,
because words, words do not
transfix in a way that video does.
And I think that words are the,
frankly the propagandists tool because
they put you in a box by calling you
names like that.
My calling the masters of ceremonies
by calling you what you were,
you're not what that is. You are. You
got it. I know we could trade
these stories all day long.
I'll just give you one more. But that
same reporter from New York Times,
Nellie Bowles, she wrote the story
when Peterson and I left Patrion,
they actually did a story on it,
which was quite shocking.
It's a horrible story filled with
factual errors. But in there,
there's a quote from the head of trust
and safety at patrion where she says,
you know,
you're not allowed to say these words on
our platform except so as I'm sure you
know Carl Benjamin, so going to like
never said those words on their platform.
I contacted the author and it's like she
just doesn't care and she knows she's
not going to get fired and why
even tell the truth. So it's like
they,
they just don't want to on that people
are doing and more frequency is recording
their interviews with
these people that we,
and that's something that I would
encourage as long it's legal to do so.
But you're on the record. So it's, it's,
it's legal because they're consenting to
the conversation even in, in California.
And we had one individual inside
CNN record, Alison Camera,
she does a long panel discussion about
voter fraud that cut the tape right
before the guy actually
brought up instances.
So something that people are doing now,
is there audio recording these interviews
for that reason and releasing the full
interview on Youtube?
Right.
So we've seen a lot of that actually
Tommy Robinson has done that. This guy,
Avi Yemeni has done that with a yes,
this Jim Jack. I would not, I would,
I would employ your audience,
never do an interview with the press
unless you audio tape it and that's for
your own, um, for your own protection
for sure. The other thing you can do,
at least in our situation is I
really only do these shows now.
If it's live right, if it's
alive, you can't edit me.
You might be able to sandbag me
and I have to be smart enough to,
to work with that. But you at least can
edit me. So Andrew Breitbart was my,
one of my mentors and he would take
this very, we were different people,
but he would take this perspective of,
you know, just as much press as possible.
I'm proudly who I am. I guess it
was a different world 10 years ago,
but he would do, he would
just give them everything. Um,
I think that there's two
different ways to play it,
but we certainly to record the
interviews is a good, a good path.
And some people are leaking us these
audio tapes and we put the, we put the,
the long version out on Twitter and Alison
Camerata at CNN was so humiliated by
this raw version of the interview
that she actually removed she,
she left Twitter because
people were tweeting at her.
All the while all this, uh,
all these angry tweets. So we talked
a little bit about anonymous sources.
What do you make of just
like the anonymous accounts
all over the platforms that
often are the drivers of a lot of
the bad behavior. So for example,
there are anonymous accounts that have 20,
30,
40,000 followers that I see all day long.
Selectively editing video clips
of me or just any, you know,
any decent human being.
And it's like they can do it with complete
impunity because their names aren't
attached to any of this. And what,
what are you going to do? What,
what do we do in situation? I mean, I,
I've got people impersonating
me and I'm not verified.
I got 500,000 followers that this morning.
I don't know who else.
I guess there's Julian Assan.
She's also not verified. Um,
I don't know how to solve these problems.
I don't know what the public
policy solutions are. My,
my perspective and I never want
to ask me what do we do about it.
I say the solution is
to inform the people.
The solution is to show people
the rot, the corruption, to,
to rake the muck as it were, to be a
muckraker to illuminate all the problems.
Because I think the solutions become self
evident when people know that there's
a guy in a room in San Francisco
arbitrarily determined, oh,
we're going to take away,
not take away the blue check mark.
We don't like that guy's politics film
that show people those conversations
behind closed doors because then they
can't get, there is impunity. They,
they can't get away with it. And
that's the, that is solution.
The solution is to expose it. Um,
what, I mean, I can't believe that I'm,
I mean,
on one hand I don't want to complain
about it because it makes it me feel like
I'm, you know, ingratiating
myself to Twitter. I'm not,
I'm not a verified human being
on the platform. And I and and,
and why not? What is the
definition of of being verified,
but certainly when you are verified, it
does help your, your stories get out.
It does. People know that it's actually
you and know you've had people,
many people in person. Amy, I don't,
I don't know what the solution is,
but I know that to find the solution we
have to properly identify the problem
and educate the people
with what they're saying.
You need a mole in the verified
department who can just click that button.
Maybe we already have one. Ah. It's still
always question is whether to cut bait.
If you will be,
if you will be verified with your blue
check by the time this video goes up,
I will be very impressed. That would be
amazing. That'll be interesting somehow.
I think you haven't been
sitting on that one. No, I I,
well the question with undercover
work is when do you cut bait?
Because you have these people who are in
on the inside and then you have to make
an editorial decision on
when do we release the story.
Like we have people right now,
right now as I speak inside the
big networks who work for them,
they come to me and they are so sick by
how these companies project themselves.
You know, all the news that's fit to
print, the most trusted name in news.
That is not what they hear in, in
the newsrooms. They here, they,
I mean we had one person
say that people were crying,
they were crying the night of the
election at the Washington Post.
Everyone was sobbing and the things that
were being said that night would shock
you.
So these people come to me,
we're calling it the be brave initiative
and we think that the heroes are,
these are these individuals on the
inside and I think that they'll blow the
whistle, they'll tape them. That works.
And hopefully that that will change
people's perception of big media once and
for all. How do you think a
Trump somehow understood this?
How is it that this orange man with crazy
hair somehow understood that like this
wasn't like he was, oh he, you know,
he was always sort of a
Twitter troll and yeah,
doing his thing and he understood the
celebrity and he understood public
relations and business obviously.
But this very specific thing that
we've been talking about for,
for the last hour,
Trump really seems to understand this.
Do you have any sense of what that is?
My perspective is that it was about earned
media that was about generating are,
and I think that there was some
something written about this where he,
his advisors said, you can't run
this campaign on earned media alone.
You have to be more traditional.
I said, the Hell I can't watch me.
And he got some, I don't know how much it
was, five, $10 billion in earned media.
Yeah. It's this, it's this notion
of, I think a lot of people,
particularly on the conservative
side of the spectrum,
tend to complain about wine, about, you
know, the mainstream media. They, they,
they, I call it the conservative ghetto.
They stay talking to themselves. But,
but then there's this other vision
where you, where are you? You,
you hack the media, you, you
participate in the media. It's again,
going back to Andrew Breitbart,
he would, he would, um, uh,
love to go on these shows
that the definition of success
is being covered by the
mainstream media in it's, it's a, it's
a tough dance because they attack you,
they call you and Julie, you know,
Jordan names and those sorts of things.
But if you play it the right way
and he covered by the media, that's,
that's real power.
And Trump understood that he could
win the election with earned media.
It was absolutely brilliant. Nobody else
saw it. Everyone thought he was nuts.
But he won the election on earned
media, on getting these big ABC, CBS,
NBC New York Times to, to cover him,
to talk about him. It was brilliant.
It was amazing. And everyone thought
he couldn't, it couldn't be done.
And he did it. And I, and by
the way, I have the same vision,
although in a lesser degree,
I tell my team,
I tell my employees the definition of
success is to get on the front page of the
New York Times because it
Manhattan, what, what you, you know,
people have to realize is that if
it is not in the New York Times,
it does not exist.
They don't pay attention
to things on the outside.
I hate to give them that power, but it's
still true to a degree. Yeah. So to,
to be successful is to be covered
by the people that we hate.
And also,
and also not to get stuck where we
want to be loved by those people. Yes.
But because that's the problem
that that is, that is the problem.
We want to be loved. And Rush
Limbaugh says, you know, I,
I learned that to be hated
as a sign of success.
And that's where a lot of Republicans
go wrong. Trump did not go wrong.
A lot of Republicans want to be loved
by the New York Times, by politico.
Um, it's tempting. I want to be loved
you. Everyone wants to be loved, right?
But we're going to be hated for what
we say and do. So it's being co,
so Trump's getting covered by them, but
he also calls them fake news. Right.
Brilliant. Yeah, it's, it's,
it's Andrew Breitbart 2.0
all right. So in, in
summation here, if you had to,
if you were in the predictions game,
where do you see the platforms?
Do you sense that the way we communicate
right now where we're all on these
things and we're all subjected to these
subjective rules and seemingly arbitrary
decisions and all of those things,
do you sense that five,
10 years from now it's going to still
be the same or do you think that things
are going to massively change?
They are only going to change
if independent citizens
have the courage and the
willpower to do something about it?
I don't trust the politicians.
I don't trust the people on television
to do anything about it because they're
stuck in the status quo
and they're fat and happy.
It's going to require citizens,
independent people. You know,
some of these insiders,
I know some of them and others,
they have to blow the whistle. They have
to summon the righteous indignation.
I think that journalism has the
power to change hearts and minds,
real investigative reporting,
uh, to, to be the, uh,
what has been called the
custodians of conscience.
And if we can shock the people,
show them what's going on
behind the closed doors, I
think it can change things.
If that does not happen,
I think we'll enter a brave new world.
Where does it happen? Where a long
gun, right? Yeah, but, but, but, but,
but there are people, I know these
people, they're going to blow the whistle.
But if that does not happen, then
we're going to enter a brave new world.
But where the story has to be so big,
here's the silver lining.
Even if we get banned,
even if you get banned and I get band,
everyone gets banned,
the stories will come out and other
people will share them proxies.
We'll share them and they will
share the information that,
that people will have a right
to know that we'll want to see.
But I think it's going
to require an effort by,
by independent citizens and brave
patriots willing to blow the whistle.
That is the only saving grace I
can see for this country. Uh, the,
the heroes amongst us that they
can, uh, to pitch a little bit.
They can go to our website
and I will give them a camera.
I will pay their legal bills,
I will hire them if they
are fired by their employer.
Twitter and Facebook have not sued me.
I get sued a lot.
I have not been sued by those companies.
They do not want to give heft and weight
to the stories that we have unmasked.
They do not want to give us free
publicity. So there is a, uh,
a strategy here to,
to hold these people accountable.
I'm going to ask you one more actually,
which is I've asked this of a few of my
guests that I think are on the forefront
of saying on popular things are doing
work that is challenging and interesting
way. What is it about you? Why? Why,
why do you James O'keefe
put your ass on the line.
If I, if, if very tasks went away
tomorrow and I had no employees,
I'd be out hustling on the street
with a cam quarter and this is I,
this is what I was born to do,
like I can't do anything else.
And it goes back to this whole
idea of a justice complex,
like the acorn investigation
that cost me $1,000 to do.
I borrowed my grandmother's
Chinchilla coat,
a camcorder that a friend gave me an a
borrowed copy of final cut pro and acorn
was defunded. Both houses of Congress
are democratically controlled.
President Obama signed the bill.
It doesn't take money to do this.
It doesn't take power to do
this. It takes, it takes will.
It takes the design.
It takes a belief in justice.
It takes a desire to,
to expose something to inform your fellow
citizens and finding people who are
likeminded.
If they were to take away my organization,
I'd be doing this for the rest of my life.
I had nothing else I could
do because I believe in it.
I actually believe in what I'm doing
and the people that I find I have,
I have a profound responsibility
to serve the, the people,
to tell the truth to the people and people
coming forward that want to blow the
whistle. This is, this is
why Veritas now exists,
is to equip those people
and to protect them.
I'd be willing to go to jail to
protect a source. I have been to jail.
I've been incarcerated, I've been
sued. I've been set up. It's not,
it's not the worst thing.
The worst thing is not to to serve the
people that come to me and want to tell a
story,
and that's why we exist and we're
going to keep doing it until people are
honest.
On that note,
you can follow James and Project Veritas
on Twitter for as long as they're still
on Twitter.
It's at project underscore very tough.